all right guys we have will clemente
joining us now to run through our weekly
bitcoin on-chain analysis that is
sponsored by ftx us
well how we doing what's up jazz it's
been a minute it has been a minute how
you doing man
chilling chilling i'm a little upset the
rangers lost last night but
you're a rangers player
yeah yeah yeah nc you gotta go hurry i
thought you were her i assumed you were
hurricanes no no no no no all my
family's from new york so i just always
went for new york teams growing up all
right cool who do you think's gonna win
the series
i don't know i think i think the rangers
have a good chance to to take it now
we're heading back to msg but
i have a feeling i don't know the canes
have been really good at home so if it
goes to game seven
i think they got the odds in their favor
we'll see though you know my dog's name
is ranger right
yeah all right cool it's not after the
team but it works oh i thought it was
nah uh how's your dog doing by the way
he's good he's passed out cold on the
floor next to me which is good how big
is he now is he getting bigger
yeah he's like 20 pounds
so when the first time i came on the
show with him he was like
12 or 13. so he's growing a bit i mean
how big he's gonna get
i think like 35 pounds
so not too much bigger we'll see but
like everyone i talked to so like with
the he's a golden doodle so he's like
three quarters poodle one quarter golden
retriever yeah everyone i talked to
says like there's different sizes so
there's like mini medium standard and
everyone's like yeah i got a mini and
ended up being 60 pounds and some people
get the
the standard which is supposed to be the
50 60 pound one and ends up being 20 25
so i don't really know what to expect
we'll see but uh at the rate he's
growing i'd be surprised if he got much
bigger than like 30 35 pounds yeah yeah
i feel like you want them uh that's like
the perfect size that's like yeah not
not too big but you could still bring
them around just a couple of dads
chatting it up over here
hey what kind of dog you got i got a
golden retriever
oh nice okay i had a golden retriever
growing up they're they're great dogs
man yeah josh
because we're
dad talking about shopping yeah we got a
couple dogs man guys
thinking about it you got a golden
doodle right
yeah yeah you just missed that i like i
like the golden doodles uh yeah those
are good-looking dogs all right let's
talk bitcoin enough of the dog talk now
we gotta move on to the stuff before
people start getting mad all right uh
what's going on with bitcoin what is
your general kind of overview 30 000
foot what you're seeing and then we'll
get into some of the charts
yeah i mean look i think
in these
these kind of current conditions you
shouldn't be trading lower time frames
unless you have some like material edge
and like
order flow or whatever maybe that you
feel like you have a short term edge in
but you know i think like
trading drawing lines on chart i don't
think is very conducive in this
environment when everything is really
driven by macro and
you know you have the the fed come out
say a couple words and then all the
lines you're drawing on a chart are just
completely blown out so
i think in this environment you should
be
more focused on the high time frame than
ever uh and you know again unless you
have some type of material edge probably
just be focusing on building long-term
positions and things you have strong
conviction in
gotcha so let's start with some of the
charts i'd love to start with the one
that talks about the price drawdown from
the all-time high what are you seeing
here
sure yeah i mean this is a pretty
straightforward charge just telling you
the amount of you know price drawdown
from the previous all-time high uh as
you can see we're currently 57 down from
bitcoin's all-time high in november of
last year uh historically we've seen
bitcoin get as low as 80 percent down
from its all-time highs uh we saw that
in 2012 when bitcoin drew down 90 which
is pretty gnarly i mean i can't imagine
you know owning only bitcoin back then
when you have no price history
whatsoever saying that you know it's
recovered that was after the first major
run-up in price so you know those people
had incredible conviction that held down
90 or were adding there uh you had a
drawdown of over 80 in 2015 as well as
2018
uh and then the other largest one was in
march of 2020 when it drew down almost
80 percent from from its previous high
so
currently you know we're we're down
pretty substantially but in bitcoin
terms you know we
you know by by bitcoin standard i should
say you know we could potentially see
you know much lower drawdowns but i
guess the caveat to that would be
we didn't reach that level of explosive
upward moves in price that a lot of
people including myself at the time
um were were anticipating heading into
you know the end of 2021
and we kind of got that that cap off and
rounded top and price that uh you know
didn't translate to the historical kind
of parabolic blow off top that we've
seen in previous market cycles so i
think there's potentially argument to be
made to say well because the top wasn't
as explosive perhaps we don't have that
you know extreme 80
drawdown
if that were to take place as it has in
the previous three you know major
cyclical drawdowns that would put
bitcoin at like 12 to 14 k if we went
down 80 85 percent peak to trough so i
don't know i personally will we'll get
to that in a moment as to where i'm
seeing value but
i think there's there's a somewhat of a
strong case to be made that because we
didn't see that parabolic price action
to the upside perhaps we don't see as
much of a reflexive you know
capitulation bottom to the downside yeah
that makes sense and and i'd love to
talk more about that through the next
few charts but let's move on to the
monthly returns uh chart that you sent
over what are you looking at here
yeah it's just uh kind of just going off
the last one of showing you peak to
trough drawdowns this is just showing
you the month uh month over month change
in price
so as you can see this is one of the the
worst monthly performances of btc
uh in its history only dwarfed by a
couple of those times that we discussed
a minute ago including you know 2018 uh
march 2020 summer of last year some of
the obvious ones you'd expect
gotcha and then when we move on to uh
the following one which is uh looking at
i i can't necessarily even read this at
the top left but it looks like bitcoin
over us dollar right uh yeah yeah what
are you looking at here
yeah i was just just showing like short
term we're just literally ranging going
sideways
um so you know nothing too exciting i
mean you have like some short-term
traders that will look to just you know
buy the bottom of the range short the
top of the range i mean maybe that's the
type of you know trading that you find
conducive for like scalper type of
entities but that's not the type of
trading again that i'm looking to do in
this type of environment
again i think especially in the
newsletter we've never really focused on
that kind of short-term you know trading
mindset we've always tried to
we view it as you know trying to help
people strategically allocate to btc
rather than you know trade it short term
but you know
i guess if you know if that's the type
of trading you're interested in you
could play the range but uh it's just
really just putting the chart in here
just to show that we've really just been
sideways for two weeks straight well i
think we have a good leads to the next
move
yeah
i think we have a good uh a good meme to
prove your point uh around this
stage you're such a dumb animal
aren't you directly
yeah that's an amazing one did you make
that
no i don't know
i would send that to elon i got a
feeling that might be posted
yeah that's a pretty solid one yeah i
like that one all right let's move on to
the next chart uh i will say oh before
before um
i like this this uh this one meme i saw
it was
hard times hard times create strong
memes strong memes create good times
you know like the fourth turning but
with memes instead of instead of it i
think it's true we're seeing some some
pretty solid memes coming out of this
bear market yeah people have more time
they're not just posting uh price
updates all the time
they have the ability to uh go make more
memes which is good exactly um all right
so let's let's zoom out and look at
bitcoin uh over a longer time frame now
which is this next chart that you have
uh talk me through why you think it's
important now to zoom out and look at
some of the stuff from this angle
yeah i think you know i've been in this
market for two years now as of the next
you know in a week it'll have been uh
two years my anniversary or whatever of
getting into btc and i think like
my
my mental framework of how i've
approached the market has evolved a lot
in that time and i think one thing that
i've learned from just a high level is
you know not over complicating things
and i think it's really boiled down to
me to
value and momentum and this is like a
mental framework that my buddy avi from
goldentree introduced to me
uh about five or six months back and
it's it's really kind of you know set
it's at home with the way i've
approached the market now
um and i think like you know the from a
high timeframe perspective you can set
you know two thresholds for yourself one
being momentum and one being valued and
so that's kind of how i outline the
remainder of the newsletter this week
so we'll start with the momentum side
obviously we're well below a lot of
these momentum thresholds but just
saying this is where i'd be
looking to get active as a momentum
market participant and you know
theoretically if we were to get up to
some of these areas so
first we're starting with
uh the 180 week exponential hold moving
average
so this is a moving average that
essentially just has more weighing to
recent price action uh whenever the
whenever the oscillator is increasing so
whenever the moving average is
increasing it's green and whenever it's
decreasing it turns red
it's pretty pretty simple
uh and so it's basically a good high
time frame kind of uh momentum or trend
following indicator to look at
and so as you can see you know whenever
this flips red it's not good
you'll see before 2018 and i posted this
a few weeks ago when we were at like 36k
the first week that we flipped right i
was like yeah this is not great from a
momentum perspective uh we're you know
flipping bearishly in that regard and
since then we've we've seen some
continued downside uh and so again that
sits around
like around 47k that's kind of the the
area of confluence i've highlighted
across all these things we'll go through
a few more from the momentum side but
that kind of sits around 47k where i'd
be looking to theoretically get active
as a as a momentum market participant
but still you know sitting well below
that
gotcha and is there any indication
around how long uh those time periods
last historically
uh i mean
i i don't think like you know we have
like three three time samples from from
going back in the rest of this chart so
i think it's difficult to like
look at three sample size and then make
any conclusions going off of that so i
would just say instead of
looking at time just look at the action
of what's being you know told by the
chart that's why we bring you on because
you're you're smart
all right let's talk about the the chart
here that has the 2022 yearly open
marked on it
yeah again this is just uh you know kind
of somewhat of a psychological level
people look at nearly open the 2022 uh
yearly open is at 46 200. we kind of
deviated above that and got you know
faced a lot of resistance when we had
that push up to around 47k
uh in april that was also a confluence
of rejection from the previous chart we
looked at
where we had a failed underside
re-tested that as well
and the next chart we'll look at as well
confluence there as well
you know so again confluence is key and
so you know back in april
we had you know several failed underside
retests of all these things i'm looking
at as momentum thresholds and to me that
was quite bearish at the time because
showing you the market is failing to
regain any type of momentum and it just
looks like a bear market re-test in that
regard uh short-term holder cost basis
something we've talked about a while on
the show
dylan's talked about a bit when he's
come on
it's essentially the average cost basis
of all the entities on chain that have
been in the market for less than 155
days
that's come down a bit as you've seen
short-term holders capitulate meaning
that their cost basis has come down
and as well as some people average down
as well let's brought that down to about
forty five thousand thirty eight dollars
if you want to be exact
gotcha and then we have uh what's the
next one realize price
if you want to talk through uh realized
price
sure so yeah so that was that was from a
momentum standpoint see that is about
47k
when we move on now to the value
framework uh we're talking about you
know like extreme value like cyclical
bottom type of areas for vtc
uh we currently see that as about 22 to
24k
um again not necessarily saying that
that is
most definitely going to happen just
saying that if you know you got to speak
in if then if then format right so if we
got to that area i would be looking at
you know that's where i'd be you know
betting the farm and
you know deploying all of my dry powder
um just because it's so pleasing to
deploy historically at some of these
levels we're about to talk about so yeah
first we'll start with realize price uh
this currently sits at 24 000 uh usd
that's essentially the you know we talk
about short-term holder cost basis but
realized price is just the absolute
aggregated cost basis uh of all the
utxos
uh and so whenever whenever price goes
below that historically that served as
an amazing buy opportunity um for people
with kind of that multi-year time
horizon
and by definition whenever price is
below realized price what that's telling
you is that you know all in aggregate
market participants are underwater right
because by definition you're below their
cost basis um and so that's where you
can start to see some major capitulation
etc uh that's kind of where you want to
be allocating historically gotcha and
then i know uh our friend z score is
back so talk to me through what you're
seeing here
yeah i love this chart i think it's um
one of the one of the best ones to be
looking at for for what we're talking
about here from from a value perspective
so this is comparing
it's another way to look at the chart we
just looked at but instead you're just
taking a ratio of price to realize price
so whenever again whenever market price
gets below realized price by definition
market participants are under water in
aggregate
and so that's when you get into that
green zone at the bottom so if bitcoin's
price was to go below that realized
price around 24 000 then that oscillator
would move down into that green zone the
green zone historically is marked
basically generational buy opportunities
for btc um so again that's an area where
if we entered that green zone that's
for for me personally of course not
financial advice uh where i'd be just
looking to deploy all of the remaining
cash that i'm sitting on
in case you know we you know in case we
we do enter that threshold uh i mean you
said what that's at 24 000
yeah uh at 24 000. and so you know that
that would be that would be to start
going into that
green zone uh you know if we started
going below essentially i have bids
ladder down from about 24 to 22k uh and
the 22k comes from the next chart we're
looking at uh i'm sorry that in a few
charts and a few charts we're looking at
so
the order but um yeah down from down
from realized price especially to the
200 week moving average uh the 200 week
the 200 week moving average has
basically caught every cyclical bottom
basically to the tick
um that's a pretty widely known moving
average that
was used in almost all markets but for
btc is has been a great uh signal and so
i have my bids ladder down from that
realized price down to that 200 uh week
moving average
interesting okay cool uh and then talk
me through the multiple here the the
meyer multiple that you're uh charting
out
sure uh so this is looking at the market
price compared to the 200-day moving
average
um not to be confused with the 200 week
moving average that we'll get to in a
moment uh the 200-day moving average i
think sits at like 44k or 45k
uh i looked at it about an hour ago
um
and so like as you can see we're very
close to where historically this is
marked these generational buy
opportunities in you know 2014 2015 uh
2018 march of 2020 and summer of last
year
not quite at those like absolute low
levels of those readings but generally
speaking for you know people who kind of
average into the asset class whenever
we're below that that green threshold at
the bottom that's a great time to to
really increase your gca
gotcha uh and then you're so good that
you're now taking the temperature of the
price uh so talk us through the price
temperature chart that you got here
sure so this was created by my buddy
dilution proof who's another uh bitcoin
analyst from that event through twitter
uh he created this metric
honestly like five or six months ago and
essentially it just looks at the amount
of standard deviations from the
four-year trend of price uh the
four-year trend was was based on the
habit and so as you can see
um each of these price levels has you
know caught this
these kind of like key pivot points for
btc pretty well but especially that
lower bound uh and so that lower bound
currently sits at about 21k
uh as you can see that that caught the
bottom in 2015 2018 2020 and we're not
quite there but we're we're getting
pretty close and again that's that's
kind of on the the bottom range of where
i have my my bids flatter down
personally
gotcha uh and then i think these next
two or three charts are the ones that
you wanted to speak more about uh let's
start with the uh just the bitcoin us
dollar one that you have here tracking
over from uh july 2016.
yeah so we talked about it a second ago
that the 200-week moving average so this
is that chart uh as you can see
historically you know whenever we get
near this 200 week would be average it's
a great buy opportunity
it sits at about 21 000
right now of course we're you know a bit
away from that uh getting pretty close
but uh again that's kind of the bottom
range of where i'd be looking to average
my bids down to
uh and then as well i don't want to get
you know too repetitive but also the
next chart sits around uh 20 400 very
similar to that two hundred week moving
average
uh except this is the 180 month uh
exponential moving average so we looked
at the 180 weekly exponential moving
average as a momentum threshold of the
monthly version i'm looking at as a
value area
um so this sits again at 24 20 400. uh
the interesting thing to note about this
uh aside from the fact that very similar
to the 200 week moving average uh it's
caught these kind of like cyclical
bottoms
it it stayed green the entirety of
bitcoin's history so again remember what
i you know said at the beginning uh the
exponential hole moving average when
it's increasing it stays green when it's
declining it turns red
so this is a good visual to show you
that you know the monthly momentum of
btc is up only over time uh because this
has stayed green throughout the entirety
of bitcoin's history so
you know this is like one of those type
of uh you know indicators you could look
at whenever you're perhaps losing that
you know long-term conviction to show
you that you know over over the long
term btc is up only
i like that i like that uh okay last
chart is the geographic premiums what
are you seeing here
yeah so um i was gonna throw some like
some other like various charts in here
but i i hit the uh like the limit on the
amount of images you could put in the
newsletter this week so i decided this
was like the most interesting of those
this is looking at the all the trading
hours based on like
the geographic areas of what those those
hours are you know essentially the
trading hours for each of those areas so
in particular looking at
asia europe in the united states and so
this in particular is comparing the
asian trading hours to the european and
united states uh trading hours and so as
you can see over the last two years
asia's really kind of dominated this
market
a lot of people kind of associate the
asians with uh you know being kind of
like the ogs of the crypto market as you
can see they they bought the uh the
coved lows they sold down increasingly
aggressively into the top of 2021
they bought back all the all the puke
from the united states and in europe at
the bottom uh in summer of last year
they sold the initial pump off those
lows bought back uh the the drawdown to
40k before that final push-up to the
all-time highs in november of last year
they didn't quite sell the exact top but
they sold extremely aggressively the
most aggressively they ever have uh in
november to december of last year
they bought back a bit at the lows in
january
and then sold down into the range highs
uh leading up to this recent move down
we've seen below 30k and since then
we've seen that premium tick up quite a
bit which is what's been catching my eye
because this is now the second highest
that the asian premium to other
geographic trading hours has gotten uh
since summer of last year so it's
something to keep an eye on you know of
course you know no one you know no no
grouper
you know individual is 100 accurate but
you know given kind of the track record
of how we've seen asia perform relative
to europe uh and in the united states
based on these trading hour premiums
this is this is pretty interesting to me
especially if we start to get up to
those levels of premium that we saw in
the summer of last year
gotcha so before i let you go uh to me
it sounds if i can just simplify uh all
these amazing charts you put down it
sounds like we're trading sideways for a
little bit of a period of time now we're
obviously declined
tremendously from the from the top but
not nearly the 80 that we had seen in
previous markets
and based on all the charts and all the
things that you're seeing from the
200-week moving average 200-day moving
average whatever it is
if it gets to 22-24 kind of range that's
when you as a long-term holder in a
long-term uh buyer someone that's dollar
cost averaging the asset that's when you
would get more aggressive is that kind
of a fair way to look at this
yeah exactly and like you know i've been
saying for a while that we've been in
kind of the lower 10 to 25th percentile
on a lot of these indicators and that
therefore it's a good time to average
into btc
but what i'm talking about here today is
like where you'd want to deploy your dry
powder for like your grandkids grandkids
you know what i mean um and that's where
you know
all the the 20 25 cash that i'm
currently sitting on you know i would be
deploying um and you know i think it
you know some people say well you know
bitcoins never faced a
you know uh
uh
macro environment of you know monetary
tightening or whatever
i think you know at the end of the day
you have to just you know make plus ev
decisions and historically these have
been
great areas to allocate historically so
uh you know that's that's where i'm
placing that's where i'm gonna be
placing my bets and and we'll see how it
plays out but uh that's kind of my view
and i think you know
macro has been in the driver's seat now
for several months um just you know the
liquidity tide's been pulling back and
with that i mean bitcoin's been just
trading tick for take with the nasdaq
we've seen bitcoin's correlation to the
nasdaq uh hit an all-time high last week
on the three-day correlation
which you know you don't love to see
right because i think we all we all
would love to see btc be that
uncorrelated asset we all believe it is
i think that's coming um i just think
you know at the end of the day you have
you have kind of these short term
correlation periods uh which are you
know somewhat spurious maybe for a few
months uh but then you know over the
long term you have this adoption curve
uh that you know lasts for the last you
know 10 10 years or so
and is going to continue out into the
future and that almost acts as a floor
that continues to push up and up and up
over time
uh and i think what what's going to
happen over the next you know call it
six to 12 months
is for bt for btc to find a bottom
you know in a in a in a disgusting macro
environment
you know you're gonna have like two
types of buyers either a you're gonna
have people who are you know taking like
a contrary bet that you know they think
that the worst
you know markets are forward-looking
right so you're gonna have people that
think the worst of the monetary
tightening is is has been you know
priced in or whatever but then you also
just have a
a group of like hardcore convicted
crypto natives right and and they're
buying you know no matter what the
current macro environment is because
they believe in the asset class and i
think you're you know this bear market
you're seeing that supply transfer to
those individuals and that's what allows
btc
to have these aggressive run-ups is
these aggressive drawdowns as silly as
it sounds um because what happens is
whenever whenever btc draws down
substantially you get rid of all the
tourists and the only people that are
buying when btc is down 60 to 80 percent
are people who have extreme extreme
conviction uh and so when you have that
supply conscience concentration to those
individuals people buying btc down
eighty percent or down sixty percent
right now uh you know those people
aren't likely looking for a ten percent
return on btc and so you know they're
looking for several multiples to the
upside and that's what really allows
that that supply concentration uh for
btc to run back to the outside and i
mean that's you know we're seeing that
in certain measures but um you know just
from not even looking at the data it's
just like logically like how bitcoin has
been able to have these big exponential
runs um and so yeah i would say um you
know
[Music]
i i wouldn't
i wouldn't place
you know your entire thesis on on
bitcoin if you have conviction on what
the current environment is uh macro wise
you know i think you you look at some of
these things and you just say
you know historically this these have
been plus ev areas to allocate
and you know it's almost like you know
okay i'm either going to buy here or you
know things are going to
be different than they ever have and i
think it's dangerous to say like this
time is ever different necessarily
because like the human
psychology is always going to stay the
same like at the bottom it's always
going to seem like it's never going to
stop going down at the top it's always
going to seem like it's never going to
stop going up so
that's that's a little i guess rambling
to to wrap it up obviously obviously
macro is important but
just saying i think you know it's at
some point you have to just look at
these areas which have historically been
super attractive and kind of put your
balls on the chop block
i like it i like it uh that was very
impressive thank you for helping us out
today with the charts i enjoy your email
as always where can other people go sign
up for your email and follow you on
twitter to make sure that they're
getting this stuff immediately
sure no thanks for having me on i know
we ran a little over on time when you
guys usually end because i was running
last minute with the newsletter so
appreciate you uh accommodating let me
on um if you're interested in the
newsletter you can go to
blackboardintelligence.com
uh my twitter i guess is up on the
screen uh and yeah i mean looking
forward to
to keep coming back on i know i haven't
been on in a few weeks i was
messing around i was at the beach twice
and then i was back home so
i'm glad i'm i'm glad i'm finally back
on with you guys and uh looking forward
to seeing you again next week hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time